up to 72 players if you're in the chat
and you want to join even if you don't
want to join you could still join by
clicking the link in the chat five four
three two and one and it's a ten-minute
tournaments it's actually two hour-long
tournaments games are ten minutes
no increments I'm playing foutch SL
let's play a Sicilian what do I want to
play good mix it up no I'll just stick
with normal normal stuff time on of 96
open Sicilian there's no rating
requirement for this tournament so you
can be any rating you can be completely
provisional it is rated so it will
affect your leach s rating there's also
no Burger King which is a new kind of
element different from previous
tournaments because previous tournaments
allows irking and then it just
encouraged lower quality chests okay so
my p5 is a line and like at first it
looks like a logical move some players
will play this without knowing anything
and those types of players usually just
end up wasting time because I'll play a
six and then the knight has to move back
I will say there is a specific way white
can kind of justify might be five but
it's not that easy to figure out
especially if you're not prepared and it
seems like my opponent isn't so well
prepared given he's already used two
minutes but Bishop III okay so the main
line after a bishop III a six would have
been Bishop d6 with a piece AK but here
let's play Knight f6
it's very possible play Queen c7 soon
transposed back into me line
hey kiyomi's and the chats
welcome back heal me I would think most
people watching are also playing but
maybe I'm wrong maybe there's there's
probably people that exists who are just
watching and not playing f3 f3 seems a
little bit committal I think I'll play
Bishop b4 and it's a sub well the thing
is way too big
shrink this a little bit thanks for the
sub chai re appreciate the support I'm
gonna put the sub notification on the
top the top right corner
okay so guerre EO is watching and
playing nice multitasking I'm
multitasking - I'm playing and drinking
Starbucks a3 think maybe I can just take
and go for d5 very intuitive decision
but this happens a lot in like these
time on of structures where I mean
White's pawn structure is a bit crippled
f3 is a bit weakening for whites because
if we trade on d5 then the bishops not
defended so rook b1 so it does have an
open file that try this to do this and
make me sad so I mean Queen c7 looks
normal
like could take and play Bishop e6 but I
don't think that's too much of a problem
I mean I could also take
then Queen takes oh let's do this
it takes on c6 I might just take back
with Queen because I'm the c3 and he for
both targeted so before I started the
strain I updated my like go-live
notification to tell people how to join
the church things but maybe not everyone
got the notification you do have to be
following me to get notified when I go
live can I do this maybe I should Castle
first you go castle King the safety
first very soon I want to play e5 the
one thing that White's has is a bishop
pair but for now the bishops are tamed
so white doves Castle let's go for
anything better
the e5 looks nice I'm trying to provoke
Knight takes c6 so I can take back and
just have a very nice Center
if the light doesn't take on c6 where is
it going
b3 or e2 or f5
might end up playing d8 soon on lining
with the Queen rook da there's Bishop d6
okay so I can't be careless
so maybe just Bishop e6
and Bishop e6 looks normal
Oh what's so link so a lot of people
like just joining you can also just go
leech s org go to play tournaments
scroll down and you'll find the Eric
Rosen arena it's a long way to do it so
I really can't complain about this
position my pieces are happy rooks are
ready to come in it is a little bit
annoying I can't play Rupp d8 because of
Bishop e6 like probably one rook will
come to see aids so Bishop c5 doing
things it's what they work on Yates am i
throwing b5 nevermind
Queen e7 and Queen d7 the Queen c7
I want to leave the d7 square open for
the night and then maybe kick away the
bishop and then maybe someday play dirty
aids
I'm also attacking a3 a guy might just
be greedy
okay he's stopping me so there are a few
choices here I could take on e4 I could
play Knight d7 I could play rook c8 and
I'll start with rook c8 cuz I want to
give white options like 97 it's obvious
that he should move back
but rook c8 make him think some more
gain some more time leaving the tension
is always nice I don't think it ever
benefits White's to take because when I
take back and my knight is happy so see
what happens
envisioning some eventual tactic 97
takes b6 vertex b6 and Queen c5 check ok
I'm expecting Bishop e3 but maybe white
will be careless I would like to see
Knight f5 because I take take and Queen
c5 in the end so Bishop e3 maybe Knight
c5 there's f2 okay
you'll still play Knight c5 just
applying pressure the Knights has good
access to a bunch of white targets
if the bishop ever takes my queen is
happy to come in and win the c3 pawn and
the move that I someday wanted to
accomplish is it's coming soon this rook
d8 but this move I forgot about I just
plunder upon maybe we're just trading I
mean I should have seen this is gonna be
annoying Oh
Knight f5 first Wow
yeah my position is actually looking
very shaky Queen our fates only move
I'm not seeing a follow-up though I'm
thinking white should have gone for this
just when the pond get rid of the bishop
wait did I put it in Zen mode what just
happened
when did that happen
I pressed a Z was it like that the whole
time how that happened
I have to go back huh I even know this
okay so rookie ones a good sign that I'm
not getting crushed instantly I could
take on a four and be super greedy but I
feel like I should defend the bishop
that's what their work here
I must have press D on the keyboard but
maybe I activated it some other way no
idea yeah why not coming out six my
Queens tied down to the Fang my knight
so I faith is not the happiest square
but it does its job and a force still
attached now I'm probably threatening to
take it even like could hop around if a
five I could be greedy I have some idea
of Bishop c4 too so I think whiteness is
a chance like how this one chance for
Bishop takes h7
but did not seize the opportunity okay
but Queen g5 still maybe scary
so take sticks
I think I'm just gonna simplify there
might be better options but this looks
very solid not sure what white is
thinking about
now I'm attacking the bishop or
attacking the Knights with the bishop
I'm attacking the pawn if Queen g5 no
Queen g5 maybe f6
actually f6 looks very nice mine a
chick's doesn't hurt me and if Queen G 4
I have g6 this line I could take on d3
why takes on b7
hmm
I really don't want to lose the b7 pawn
maybe Queen e7 queen can breathe I'm up
a lot of tying and I'm winning upon okay
things are looking better this is a
square for whites
maybe Bishop f5 some x-ray vision
this is also a square let's play Queen
d7 I think there's some nice
coordination like the Queen the bishop
the rook they're all talking to each
other
I'll move the bishop back rook d2 coming
maybe this coming - hey it's bits from
coward pawn thanks covered pawn so white
wants to win b7 I want to win the king
I'm trying to find accurate moves 32
takes Queen d5 the Queen d5 immediately
there's also night a five-way truck D -
I'm just winning the rook I forgot this
is a discovery now I can take if rook
takes probably Rupp t1 otherwise now I'm
up the exchange you need to show some
technique rook be sixes of threats so
maybe he wrecked the eights I'll be very
happy to trade rooks okay let's be solid
some guys with emotes don't play f6 but
sometimes you have to disappoint and
fine gold part of life let's play this
and now this is a pretty explosive
square for the Knights
rook d2 maybe a five a five will trot
the bishop ooh there goes my pawn let's
go back that's sad
I'm missing my a pond had some like
emotional attachment to that pawn 93
looks nice so because g2 is hard to the
fence and I'll snatch it
New York c2
and the plan is this this and meet it's
kind of a race like why wants to Queen I
want to meet I think I'm winning the
race so there's only thing that can
defend the pawn is a rook and then I win
this pawn and then I'll still mate
eventually if I don't may it a flag and
life is good
okay interesting game there's one point
I don't know what was this move Oh II
takes d5 I think I got a little bit
careless I should have been aware but
light should have taken on h7 would have
been a lot scarier
okay back to tournaments if you're just
joining there's a viewer tournament you
can type exclamation point join then the
chat if you want to play if you don't
want to play you can watch I have two
points it's for people with four points
this is a no buzzer keying tournaments
this is also a rated tournament could I
play the Italian if I'm whites and my
opponent plays 'if I've just for you so
we're 20 minutes in the thing about ten
minutes just seems can take up to 20
minutes so trying to do the math three
games and power I mean theoretically I
could only play six games this
tournament I'll play e4 and we're gonna
see an Italian getting ready for it us
assume Yoon
okay so I'll play Knight c3 Sicilian and
while playing can you explain every
threat and long-term plan that's what I
try and do anyway sometimes I forget but
okay we have a what do we call this
grand prix it's some sort of ROFL emo
type thing this is a move - six is
questionable because I can take
immediately and play e5
I'm gonna try and punish black I might
be overly aggressive but this looks very
attractive because the knight has to
move I this dream last night where I was
showing examples of when to push the
pawn when not to push the pawn when the
pawn can be a weakness when it's a
strength looks like more of the strength
in this position I think I'll play Queen
e2 Queen e2 is useful preventing Bishop
a6 I'm not scared of 9.4 cuz I have
Queenie 4 I'm also trying to discourage
d6 some of takes those are a pin on the
the e-file and I'm also supporting the
pawn so moves like this this and this
upon will already be somewhat defended
now I think long term just because aunt
Divi was asking movie 6 u6 is a little
bit weakening usually black should play
d6 well now if I do this there's not
enough for so I think I'll start with
this I was going to say long-term I want
to do this and this and this and then
this and this and then this and then
like eventually we'll get some Sun up
later this Bishop has a very hard time
entering the game like even if it goes
to a 6 especially if I get in pawn see
for the bishops just dead and c4 it will
kick the night away
I play these types of positions before
and it can sometimes be hard for black
to find active play so a5 is interesting
he wants to play Bishop a6 I guess I'll
play 94 c5 is potential long-term
weakness here ugh 1 - welcome back
wait kramnik quits what does that even
mean like he quit chess I know he had a
disappointing tournament but what are
the details I have not been following
chest news maybe retire it is probably
more properly quit but okay maybe after
turn there like that you can can use the
word quit c4 c4
let's do it
I do not read the chest newspaper so I
don't think the chest newspaper exists
what is this the free nights as he
climbs earlier I was I was the one blind
because I was playing blindfold chess
and it was difficult and now I
sympathize with blind people maybe it
was just to get a pawn in the center
rather than the Knights I kind of want
to do this even though it feels wrong
let's do this eventually I want to
attack on the Kings side
um Bishop here looks nice it's always
nice when you can align your bishop with
your opponent's Queen just kind of the
positional rule she allowing your bishop
with your pawns queen king or rook any
piece that's of higher value I think now
Oh Castle
I'm sorry and I bothers blocking links I
don't know how to change it so I could
take I could play my h5 rookie one looks
natural play rookie one because this is
a pretty big focal points
trying to figure out how to best attack
maybe this this and this in sack apiece
yeah I got most of my chest news from
the chest subreddit which maybe isn't
the best place for news but there's I
mean I basically see anything that's
trending from there so blog wants to
play rook beam and win be to take stakes
I mean we could trade I have 95
tray them play 95 immediately but then
there's f6 probably a position I should
not overthink there's one line I'm kind
of liking Knight g5 h6 I'm seeing a very
nice trap which I think I'll go for oh
but he takes on g5 I can't take first so
there it takes on g5 takes takes that's
not good okay I'm gonna play Queen d2
I'm getting off the diagonal of the
bishop
if recopied I play rook e1 I'm kind of
just going with my original idea I still
might want to play Knight h5 in Bishop
h6 as it looks reasonable
I would think Kramnik will come out of
retirement at some points like Kasparov
retired but then he he came out to play
some exhibitions and st. Louis chess
club events okay so take stakes
now let's play 9 h5 now I think Bishop
h6 is actually a real threats because a
pawn is pinned to the rook and if it
takes and I get my queen in and just
meets
the one thing I did hear that was
related to Tata Steel was the story of
Sam Shanklin going through customs and
the customs agent I assume this is true
the customs agent said something like
okay you're allowed back in the country
but don't don't resign in a drawn
position ever again there's something
like that which is a reasonable kind of
statement as a customs agent so you
don't want people allowed in your
country who sign in lost position or
resign in drawing positions what wait no
no I didn't want to play the ship g3
what was that I've click-click turned on
so it's annoying sometimes but my
opponents so generous not even taking
the free nights
the night was semi free I would get a
little bit of compensation but now now I
just have overwhelming compensation I'm
not losing material I guess I am losing
the pawn block wants to take and then
take here but then it's just made into
so this is a very nice position
man whatever PD has ten points already
to start winning more games more quickly
okay I'll take ya this is going to be a
nice feast of pawns
looking for some quick meets I have rook
takes East six but I don't think that
leads to much okay so I'm going for this
take on f7 take on e6 take on d5
probably 594 there's some ideas of this
so I'm up a piece
yeah this is good enough if King here I
fork if King here I win the pawn with
check if King here everything's winning
he can be vive ok I mean Rick being one
looks nice he plays 83 this is really
not a position to overthink maybe night
here forking the Queen in the pond and I
would like to just keep winning stuff
while attacking the king and just keep
initiative and eventually mates mm-hmm
let's take care
are we will see King before King before
where's the mates King a five I'll take
here
just want to take here next we're
playing this this is a fork and a
discovery attack on the Queen it's hard
to follow the chats sometimes
ooh this is a massive attack I'm
attacking literally all of the major
pieces what the fork Knights yeah
resignation was the best response to
that and move okay so I'm in sixth place
whatever PD is crushing it oh but he
drew a game so lost the streak all right
playing chess nope chess good luck
play e5 someone wanted an Italian
earlier so maybe I'll play an Italian
from the block side
you said French please a little bit too
late sorry about that I would have
played the French you said it earlier so
I have I still have time to come back
hour and 27 minutes left in the
tournament
my opponents playing very slowly - three
okay so not quite an Italian and have a
four Knights there's a few main moves
for whites this is one of them for
Knights Scotch playing mainline and
Bishop e4 is a typical move this is an
opening I've played since childhood for
both sides ax villager you did hear
correctly but ax villager do you play
for Knights scotch or do you play
mainline scotch f3 so I've three I'm
very tempted to take and then play Queen
h4 I does it work maybe it works
I mean there's taking on c6 when I take
on c3 takes takes takes takes I'm up a
pawn
if take c4 takes you for Queen h4 or
King e2p nitu can be the problem
actually I mean I could take on c3 yeah
I actually don't see a solution after
Keaney too which is a bit unfortunate it
looks good but I've been in these
situations before where I go too crazy
and then I'm down the piece so let's be
a little bit more civilized what to play
I'll play this maybe a d5 looks very
thematic because I'm ready to castle in
one move
I want to open up the center putting a
media pressure on e4
why can't play e5 because I take if
Knight takes takes and e5 probably have
27 if this should be 5 I probably just
Castle and then in some cases sack upon
4 initiative
yeah never fly off three never play off
three in the Scotch usually not a good
move to play in the scotch
there is a Queen h4 variation in the
Scotch but it's only in mainline scotch
I don't think I can play them it's four
nights okay so yeah I'll castle so why
could take twice on c6 you have takes
takes takes I am gambling gambling a
pawn maybe this g4 okay so he's going
for this
so if Knight takes I can take your first
and then Queen d6
and then I have a double threats of
taking e4 and also taking the Knights I
mean the knight has to move I think
maybe there's this move actually this is
interesting
so if Knight takes there's Queen takes
if I take there's a fork but I mean if
white takes here I have rook e8 and the
King is pretty naked and then I can take
on d5
and if night retreats and I take on e4
or maybe even consider Bishop a6 so I'm
liking the condensation ax villager I
have played Queen h4 again Scotch it's
dubious but it's a great opening against
like anyone below anyone below 1500
won't know what to play against its and
like White has to understand some
difficult moves or at least some
slightly unusual moves to get a good
position after I pushed my D pawn could
you have done the knight sac that I
previously mentioned Oh after it Bishop
g4 or after Bishop e5 it would have
given me a headache
it's a flank Knight takes e4 here just
because White has options like like good
throwing this or this or take first and
there's just so many things to calculate
but like I just saw castling it's was
way more intuitive the wayward Queen
variation is e4 e5 Queen h5 I believe
but maybe it's similar okay so this is a
move if I take we trade Queens I could
play this preventing light from castling
and threatening this and also
threatening this looks good
very multi-purpose and this is a big
threat and like it's a triple fork
and if white has to defend then not take
your next and the king will just be
stuck
yeah when I said v like below 1500 I was
probably referring to us rating and not
online rating
let's take c3 is gonna fall I mean Y
could take and a counter-attack but my
king is just much much safer in all of
these variations like such a such a nice
shelter
okay so white has essentially two moves
pawn takes or Queen takes take cure
so there's King f2 that's still a little
bit complicated maybe I have Bishop e6
which is a move I do not see ahead of
time that this might just be very simple
let's imagine King off to Bishop u6
Queen
maybe there's Bishop d2 but then I take
and I'll be able to exchange and then
because ticks I can take on each one
okay I think life is good
yeah do other countries have ratings
systems because the u.s. just has like
us raining this position I'm just up a
full rook trying to think of countries
with their own rating system I know
Canada that has their own rating system
but I would think most other countries
just use feed a like everywhere in
Europe just has feed a Australia has
their own rating system I actually
haven't Australian blitz rating and a
regular rating too but like the first
Australian blitz term and I played and I
did really well in my blitz ratings high
2500 so I think which rook let's move
this rook there's to open files so
presumably my other accounts to be on
the B file
I guess Queen c2
my queen is stuck but that I have Bishop
d3
yeah I mean blacks upper rook nice time
advantage so relatively smooth starts in
just over 40 minutes in toilet noggin
finally joining been waiting for the
toilets to arrive yeah let's do this I
remember now I hit g6 after queen h5
yeah you deserve physical punishment for
doing that especially if it's something
that you've learned it before or been
taught before okay so my pieces are
coming to life yeah I would like to
deflect the Queen away from defending a2
or defending c3 so actually the only
save square is Queen a3 but then maybe I
do this it's a battery I also do this in
this
this looks nice
there is Bishop g5 and things get a
little bit weird there's some line
Bishop g5 I take white takes and then I
mates on anyone it could happen it could
pre move this oh I shouldn't pretty move
that because there's a Bishop b2
potentially there's also Queen e7 but
then I take on e2 and play rook a fades
King g3 being patient well I'm still
stuck because the bishops defended let's
play h5 I mean we're both kind of stuck
Queen stuck but everything is stuck like
defending each other
so eventually white will run out of
moves or more likely run out of time
okay so Queenie seven decent move by
Brooke here
so if rook F eighth or would maybe be
this should be maybe annoying
now both pawns are undefended but
White's gonna flag let's take the bishop
okay good game yeah that's why you
should never play off three man Eugene
all 16 points double my score
it's impressive with no buzzer King but
I guess it's just a matter of winning
quickly yeah I got rid of the berserk
you'll because I'm trying to encourage
higher quality chess and not just trying
to flag people or like play super
aggressively and plate quickly okay so
the fifth place bunch of people still
have in me there's a hundred fifty eight
players I forget what the last pure
tournament had I don't think we broke in
two hundred that yet
so there's people watching that haven't
joined yet you should join it and play
at least one game and then leave just to
get the number up whoosh yes I can I
think I can check me with knight in
Bishop even against stockfish okay hey
I'm playing I'm playing are Beasley
student of mine good luck are Beasley
what do I play no his strengths and
weaknesses okay let's play this
someone wanted an Italian earlier so
I'll play an Italian Bishop c4 and I
think I'll just play I know there's a
few ways to play the Italian there's an
aggressive way and then like a quiet way
I'm a bit inclined to play the
aggressive way yeah let's some let's
test him
I was watching John Bartholomew extreme
earlier and he played exactly this way
it's very tricky if black doesn't know
what to do because there's some very
forcing lines and this was one of the
very first openings my coach taught me
back when I was 8 years old we kept a
notebook of my my chess openings in
starting with 93 this is really just the
beginning of all the fun in white
sacrificing a pawn this is called the
molar attack and actually why could be
sacrificing two pawns if that wants to
take on c3 but essentially white is
prioritizing development piece activity
to get some initiative later
you have white or if black takes with
either piece okay if my takes it's funny
John Bartholomew had this exact position
about what was it about ten hours ago
but John's opponent played Bishop e7
which is probably the better move Bishop
takes c3 this is still my opening
preparation from when I was eight years
old this is one of my the very first
things my my teacher taught me so I I'm
sacking two pawns I'm also now sacking a
rook if he wants to take it but I do
have some attack and some pawn and the
bishop and I think there is a moment I
don't when I was like 10 or 11 years old
I played some like National scholastic
championship and got this position and
had like an 18 move game where it was
just all preparation the game ended with
some kind of neat that I had studied
like previously so it'll be interesting
to see if this game goes down in the
same line
I don't want to say too much though
leave some of the position of her
mystery so he's okay he's tossing me
taking the rook so the point is that I
don't care about my rook I don't care
about my pawns I care about winning the
king and the move to play is Bishop g5
which just about wraps a queen black
only has one way to save it which is 97
whoa that's a move I have I seen the
smooth before I don't think I've seen
this move before now I have to think
because usually Bach plays 97 and like
97 was still this like mean lion which I
had many years ago but okay Knight takes
d4 so I could take but that allows Queen
takes and I'm down a lot of material I
could just play Queen a3 that's probably
simplest and then when the Queen Queen
a3 yeah
this is good enough sadly for black
there's no move to defend both of these
if Queen e7i just meets fd6 I take and
then they'll all be up somes for the
material he can't capture the knight
because he's in check oh maybe you're
were you asking why I can't catch for
the Knights if I were to capture this
Knight then my bishop would be
undefended
okay so I'll win the Queen and this
Bishop is still attached
so we're probably getting some position
where all of a queen for rook Bishop and
a couple pawns but black will just be
hundred develops so it could still be a
fight and do I take the bishop
probably oh there's also 95 or Knight g5
so much fun
9 g5 9 g5 king g6 let's do it
if King g6 I can then take the bishop of
King takes I have 27 and this might
combined with the Queen will be a good
attacking combination hey it's Jill
Collins
welcome to the live stream every stream
there's some some new people feel free
to say hi in the chats okay now I'm like
I don't know if I even want to take the
bishop I just want to go after the king
could do this
maybe play like queen here
I'd like to be a little more subtle
Queeny seven or calf eights maybe queen
c5
I'll just take I am allowing a fork but
I'm allowing it intentionally yeah this
is uh this will be nice I guess black
has d5 but I just want to see King h8
King h8 would be nice then there's some
smothered meats
but whatever happens I mean this is
already pretty winning but smothered
mate would be some nice icing on the
cake
okay so now I'm attacking h7 I'm some
sort of mini pawn pork
Patrick James he is back what were you
before you became a people what does
that even mean okay now I have another
fork the forks are unstoppable
I guess there's rook d7 sadly were we're
not seeing smothered means yeah a tough
game this is a game I mean can't play in
my opponents just walking into opening
preparation I could just show the
completion of the line like the main
line if black plays 97 there's ninety
five curious how many people have this
in me chess yeah over 100 the idea with
95 is nice like opening up Queen f3
so Bishop takes T for Queen or maybe
Bishop g6 first yeah
then g5 and then Queen f3 and this is
just completely crushing so yeah it's a
dangerous line the move to play is
Bishop takes c3 and then there's some
complications like I would play d5 and
then black should save the bishop I
would play rook e1 black should save
this Knights and this is essentially the
main line where black is up upon but it
continues for several more moves and I
could probably spend like a good half
hour just showing this like this opening
theory but okay let's go back to
tournaments very nostalgic game 4th
place and Eugene all unstoppable so far
but I am making some headway
trying to break into the top three
yeah it's hard to play on instinct when
you're in some like very well-known
theory that requires some
counterintuitive moves are some very
like deep understanding but ok that's
how you kind of learn over time so I'm
playing useless player
sounds like a username with not the
highest self esteem what do I want to
play I forgot to play a French so I'm
playing a 6 ok I'm maybe will transpose
into some French who knows no we're
having a time on earth so this is a
second time on earth of the tournament's
personally it's one of my favourite
openings for black NC 4 it's been mine
in my like main tournament repertoire
for many years and it's flexible I
usually do this in this I was explaining
this yesterday and my bishop decides
where it wants to go
sometimes I'll play b5 so we'll see what
happens
actually I think both my black games so
far have gone down similar type of lines
where my opponent plays the early f3 I
have my Bishop on before and I played d5
so maybe we'll see it again in this game
ok this is one of the the main lines see
f3
and there's actually some very sharp
theory emerging from this line as far as
I know 95s I mean move I know d5 looks
attractive there's some reason why g5
shouldn't be played but I forgot why 95
there's some goal of 94 I'm also
unleashing the Queen if a 3 then I take
and then go for d5 I mean I could draw
arrows over every square of the board
but that would be kind of obnoxious
so King B 1 usually white plays Knight B
3 can be won maybe now d5 let's play d5
now I forgot all the nuances I know 93
is usually played to like discouraged
Knights or discouraged pawn to e5
now okay now 93 interesting so I could
take on c3 I could take on you for two
there's some weird tactic like take on
e4 and Knight b5 could actually be
unpleasant
so I could castle
you things get a little bit complex
takes takes calculating taking on c3 and
then taking on e4 and then castling I
take on c3 of them play Knight c4 that
actually looks reasonable Knight c4
[Music]
just trying to make sure there's no
tactics along the D file buddy it's
covered and I just want to get some
structure I understand
white has to concede that the disrepair
expecting bishop takes c4 if the Queen
moves I'd probably just take on III
and then whenever I get the chance I
want to Castle and be happy oh so we
have another person watching mine for
the first time yeah there's a whole
different dynamic between twitch and
YouTube and again going back to watching
John Bartholomew earlier he had a really
good quote explaining the difference
between twitch and YouTube he was saying
like Castle here I think at Castle he
was saying that when he does content for
YouTube it feels like recording a
lecture when he does content for twitch
it's like delivering a lecture so it's a
whole different dynamic okay so white
wants to attack me
I want to attack the King it's actually
relatively safe I could bring the knight
and like bring the Knight to a4 and put
the Queen on b2 it takes some time but
I mean that's what time is for just
matter of getting pieces to better
squares 90 the night being on a four it
would be a very nice square I don't know
what these pawns are doing
seems like White's attack should be a
little bit slower I mean all it takes is
one two three more moves and already
after a night a four I'll be threatening
made into
I'm imagining including rook deeds can
maybe be a move start with nine a four
because C 3 is also targets on my plate
we nee 5 and go after a c3 you don't
think pieces move that way
well they do move that way it just
sometimes takes more than one move so
the Queen a5 I'm attacking c3 how those
white defenders 92 or Bishop t2 but then
b5 play b5 immediately I'll do this
first
I think the eventual plan is like b5
rook b8 b4 and be happy always afraid of
castling kingside in the Sicilian I
assume from blacks perspective
I mean sometimes it depends I think if
for some reason I have a pawn on h6 orgy
6 then White's pawn storm would be much
more terrifying because white could
force files to open but when all my
pawns are back it's very hard for white
so actually open up lines to get to the
king it's like even with the pawns here
they're not really doing much usually
white needs some kind of hook to open
the position so b5 erupted units
or Bishop d7 you know play b5 it's going
to be hard to get in b4 as a bishop in
pawn form a battery but b5 solidifies
things so rook the it runs on tonight c6
so probably the Queen should go back to
c7
and I think what I want to do is play
Bishop d7 a 5 B 4 that way the bishop
sports the Knights I could be sacking
upon but then I'll open the a file
Marvel Thor saying hello question mark
hello they said this would be seven
Queen e7u maybe now rook e8
I mean this is an open file I might
actually be threatening me five here
does it's a skewer or a pin I think the
Chad is quieter than normal because
everyone's playing the tournament
they're focused on their own games f6
looks good
always playoff six and Bishop has to
retreat whoa treating all the way so
iffy five nine five five takes takes
rook d7 I don't know
I want to make something work
I think I might go for a queen trade
because I'm liking the the queenless
middlegame
whereas III becomes more of the targets
then I don't have to worry about any of
whites attack I can focus on D file play
I think White has to trade Queens 2
because there's nowhere for the Queen to
hide
wow there's lots of new viewers welcome
to the new yearís toy wagon is one for
five or is it one in five
if only there were ways to this track
toilet noggin to make up for all the
times he distracts me can i play a five
a five looks actually it looks bad I
mean I could take on the c3 that looks
good tactics
have to make a new rule that every time
you unleash a tactic you have to say
tactics that would be a bogus rule whoa
what is this counter tactics but I can
take I think these tactics are favouring
me if truck takes me five I take and
then take life is good
it's taking me longer than normal to
drink my chai latte because I ordered
the the latte first of all the the
barista was having a hard time
understanding me but I said chai latte
and then she asked he wants Syrah which
no barista has asked me because usually
it just comes with serif by default so
man I was confused like was she asking
if I want extra syrup so I said a little
bit so I wanted to be cautious
okay good game and now now I have a chai
latte which is just a little bit sweet
but much less sweeter than normal it's
mostly they're just like chai what chai
tea and milk basically with no sweetness
I wanted to dessert but there's no
dessert button let's play ghee for
so it's taking me a little bit longer
and then she asked for my name and I
said Eric and she gave me a very
confused look I've run into a lot of
people did I play here let's play f4 and
be aggressive a lot of people have a
hard time pronouncing the arse so and
like they cannot pronounce the arse as
owls so I said Eric and she wrote down
let me show this me play g3 she wrote
down this she wrote down Alex which was
kind of funny because when I was like 5
years old I had a hard time saying my
name and instead of saying Eric because
I had a hard time announcing my arse I
also like I said something that
resembled Alex like Alec it's something
like that and they also don't like a lot
of people don't pronounce asses here
they all ask for ice and stuff and
they'll say I slowly learning the accent
okay so we have doesn't even really
paying attention to what's going on in
this position we have a closed Sicilian
but I want to play aggressively so I
think I'll go for like the standard
development and then if I'm given the
chance I just want to play f5
I'll castle first I'm holding off on
playing d3 because I don't I might want
to play d4 at some points but now it's
probably time to make up my mind
that's why d3
probably a five coming next act hasn't
touched anything on the kingside so I'd
like to open things up on the kingside
f5 right away it looks nice I do this
for a few reasons one reason I would
like access to d5
I would like my rook to be happier I
might want to play Bishop h3 like
there's some threaded like taking my g5
Bishop h3 and if a pawn lands on e6 like
if we trade on e6 and a pawn stays here
and then it's a big target
where do I live at the moments I mean
for the moment I'm pretty nomadic it
takes takes 92 then II five so maybe I
take care of first
mmm-hmm so Bishop h3 or 9595 there's 97
queenie - i have 96 threats I'd be very
happy if Bishop takes d5 because then I
just keep initiative and the e-file
opens and I think black is suffering
because like the I mean the kingside
pieces are not in the game the King
still in the center think a little too
much time was used to push the Queen
side pawns instead of finding safety for
the King and now it's a matter of
actually using these these nice open
files probably expecting like c7 so
Knight g5 looks pretty direct defending
attacking also threatening this
and this ripple probably wants to say on
f1 the other rook would love to come to
you one at some points there's it's only
a few ways black can defend the pawn 96
is one way and then I play this if this
and this if this and me still this or
this or even queen h5
okay so things are good and Joanna's in
the chats
welcome back Joanna good to see you
night h6 okay so Bishop h3 Queen D
eights Queen f3 let's do it
I mean I would like to provoke at 6:00
or Queenie 7 I mean Queenie sevens just
winning immediately
what's my least played opening probably
Greenfeld almost never go into anything
Greenfeld really even a 5 I forgot about
its I would like to offer us off with my
Knights but that's not legal
Queen h5 there's g6 good take that
doesn't really lead to anything so maybe
96 first but what's the threat I need
six Knight takes d5 Bishop takes h6 that
looks good enough
I just want to get a pawn to e6 I also
want to unleash this bishop I have some
threat of taking and then queen h5
there's 211 players
nice good turnouts
I don't think I'm gonna win this
tournament Eugene Hall is just running
away with it
24 points hard to keep up with wait if
reading an earlier comment from Getty
Getty you would have a hard time
pronouncing our it's a capital R with
like a squiggly line over it no idea
what that means
so it was my plan just to take on each
six and probably to take on f5 hmm it
takes I have I've rook e1 and the 96
does a great job at preventing black
from castling
so if I want to make any sort of running
for first place I have to start winning
games more quickly which means I have to
be playing more quickly let's take on
that 593 looks like a fork Knights but I
can do this
counter-attack there's only two legal
moves for black there's this or this if
Keeney seven maybe just rook e1 takes
and like Queen h4 I mean okay I'm also
having ideas of this move too at some
points
and it's a winning position it's just a
matter of converting and the quickest
way possible so Queen f7 I'm looking for
meeting ideas so Keaney 7:00 check
and sorry with check
again two legal moves I'll probably just
bring the other rook in like I have all
of my pieces doing amazing work
this is this is teamwork right here if
Knight takes f1 I have a double
discovery oh this is also mates that's
not nice mates
okay back to tournaments second place oh
I'm one went away
I forgot I can go up by increments of
four when it was 16 to 24 it felt like a
far away's away but damn a bit closer
why not 97 Queen h5 was faster are there
any good free chess books look
untestable
there's a lot of free content on
chasuble I believe just go chasuble calm
I need to get around to making something
for chasuble I'm recommending it to
everyone but I need to eat something of
my own sipping on the site znation chess
you're back again
okay so we're playing a budapest because
I feel like it's and yeah for those
complaining about the tournament format
yesterday's stream I basically let the
viewers decide how the tournament would
be or did I flip the coin I may have
just flipped a coin determining for
rated or unrated so I go back and watch
but the Titan control was determined by
the viewers ten minute was the most
popular request is this live not AGM no
this is this is in the past
this is way far away in the past at
least for the people watching on YouTube
let's castle if you're watching on
twitch it's probably in the present
unless you're watching them the replay
which then would make this also in the
past if you're watching from the future
congratulations
wait I'm just confusing myself let's
play d6
so we have some Budapest declines I want
to play f5 at some points I played this
move usually don't see this trap but I
think I'm just winning a pawn here
Canadian historian with a sub thanks
Canadian historian I'm going to Canada
for the first time in my life but I
don't think it counts I'll be going
there for a few hours because I have a
layover in Toronto
I'll need Tamika make a longer trip to
Canada oh this is very nice
like sometimes my g4 is played to just
prepare f5 but in this case I mean f2
can't sufficiently be defended Bishop e3
is probably the best move I'll take with
Knights want to keep my dark squared
Bishop toilet noggin is leaving adios
I thought watching me was work though
maybe there's other types of work do I
have any long-term chess schools most of
my chest schools are related to teaching
and just producing online content and
not necessarily playing I would like to
improve at least my rapid blitz and
bullets because I feel like that's the
direction chess is heading there is
gonna be more competitive like online
events and even if my classical play is
subpar maybe I can roll with higher
level players and faster time controls
but no I'm not going for the genome
title if you want to learn more about me
there should be a bio commands if you
type an exclamation point bio in the
chats it should take you to my websites
so I played a 5-2 stop before also to
preserve the bishop in case of this I
always thought this with a 7 and now
it's time for f5 oh there's no bio
command that's so sad
wait I might be able to add it was it
add a commands
I don't know if this is gonna work I
think that worked though but I don't
think it's gonna be a link oh it's not a
link I messed it up
I googled earlier how to like changed
nightbot commands my play here could
play a four I'll play a four because I'm
fixing white spawns and I want to
control the be three square because
there might be some long-term ideas
bringing the Knight to b3 okay let me
try this one more time I'm rosen.com
slash by the way
now I have to use like commands edits
did that work I think that works I think
now it's actual an actual link and
better have words but there's some like
downtime where if you just expand it
then it stops working
so don't spam it bishop g6 okay so this
bishop actually both bishops are just so
happy like they're controlling so many
squares in White's territory that's the
power of the bishop pair how to join the
tournament use the joint command that's
a command that should be working takes I
want to just sack but probably doesn't
work wants to play h5
I'll play Queen f6 attacking also having
some ideas of this some invasion I've
answered this already
why no beserk option so I want to
encourage higher quality chess
buzzer King is I don't know I wanted to
create a fair playing field for everyone
if I enabled buzzer King then I would be
more inclined to beserk and then I
wanted to keep the game's more
instructive while keeping things
competitive but if people really want
the zurka I'll add it back for future
tournaments
and why no increments I could've added
increment again I let people decide what
the time control would be and 10 plus 0
at least about 12 hours ago
12 hours ago 24 hours ago wait I can
take the nights and that wins upon
okay I think what I'll do I'll play
Queen out for first than 92 I'm gonna
for 92
if I take maybe I can take and take on a
three in the end let's do that
I have to worry about this a little bit
and taking on a three looks so fun I
guess I'll take here there's a Bishop d3
so maybe h6
I'm so conflicted right now from the
page six I probably just have to play
normally like 97 and rook a f8 Budapest
reversed London not really because it's
a keen sides Bishop developing not the
Queen side bishop okay the structure may
be sort of comparable to
that'll work f2 looks nice
and then again like this whenever you
have a pollen chain with the bishop
right outside the pawn chain it's a very
harmonious way to develop okay so all
complete developments maybe my knight
will find its promised land on b3 or
maybe I'll go after the Jeep on
the bishop wants to be on d4 there is
might be five ideas
yes I'll drop the bishop back
it's just a solid position like
everything's covered
I'll bring the rook to fates eventually
these pawns should fall I think I played
chess Network many times mostly in
bullets I forget our exact score we've
definitely gone back and forth I can't
recall playing in in a longer time
control okay let's play with two
that's a good sign put the knight on c5
and the bishop will come to a5
yeah Ruka fun I don't really want to
trade this could be an interesting move
let's trade I'll bring the king to a
better place like it's hard to stop this
King attacking both pawns maybe I'll
play 94 interesting so takes King up
since the bishop lands on f5 I have each
five in the end that should be winning
it is risky going into an opposite
colored Bishop ending because there's
these weird drawing chances but I think
things are under control because I'll
probably win I mean if I went either G
pawn I'll have a passed pawn on the the
Kings side and the Bishop f5 is this
useful move h5
so Eugene all keeps winning which means
I have to ramp up the speed the h5s very
nice she can't take it and this is going
to be a queen very soon
it would be for a beer fork I would have
on passant I think as we saw it in the
game now there's this move
white would love to on passant this way
okay back to tournaments third-place man
this guy has been playing so many more
games than everyone else
okay playing whatever PD
I'm gonna be aggressive let's play don't
want to play I'll play a Belgrade
gambits it's a nice open I think Knight
takes d5 is already a mistake it's like
this is amazing for whites he wants to
play Queen before which I can't really
stop yeah let's play this should be to
play Bishop e3
okay still a nice position I'm a little
bit sad that Queens are traded but I
mean white is still probably a little
bit better just good space advantage I
could still go for some attack the
bishops have some scope his ideas of
this and this
let's start with h4 yeah I want to play
Knight g5 there's some interesting trick
if h6 I can do this yes I think this is
very nice I think White's winning
material actually because the rook has
to move and then I take and when h6 and
the bishops will flourish
black could sack the exchange that's
also nice or sack of bishop was very
generous
okay I'm getting my attack despite
trading Queens pretty early attack is
still here not seeing any immediate mate
you don't throw in the smooth
and then probably this
take this neither passed pawn
put them dish up here and now I'm just
trying to win as quickly as possible yes
you can still join the tournament there
are just under 19 minutes left in the
tournament if you want to join click the
link in the chat or type in exclamation
point join and then click the link in
the chat
okay this pawn is unstoppable I think
and yet bishops are too strong
okay you'd gain whatever PD I think he
played a little bit too quickly worked
out nicely
so I'm tied for first still in second
place
Eugene all playing grabthar's hammer now
I'm playing you 84 I'm gonna play a
London
Ivan played a London that never mind
we're gonna play a pier it's or a modern
I'll play the line with Bishop c4 and
Queen e2 it's a nice variation and E 5
very aggressive way to play against the
modern blurtin this opening about a
month and a half ago 98 some move in
white supposed to Castle six
you don't place III I'm anticipating a
French structure earlier like d5 will be
played but should here I see five and
then the D pawn will be supported ninety
six so black staying flexible Bishop g5
is interesting I think I'll start with
rook t1 just aligning the the rook with
a queen so the D file opens my rook will
be happy if d5 I moved back and the C
point can advance okay so the shove g5
why nots
if f6 I can take and win e6 so I think
Queen d7 is forced which is a good sign
but what to do maybe 92 and then 9 f1
okay so now we have a French structure
or than why it wants to go to g4
yeah the night on g4 can be very nice in
conjunction with the bishop because both
pieces will control these nice squares
I'm just trying to make a thumbnail so
c5 let's start with this this is
probably a decent threats as of night a
excited fork and if Bishop takes I get
rid of the best defender okay so I could
take the knight and then play Knight f6
or Knight f6 right away and then they
take Sam Bishop eight shades takes
so now I have six takes takes Bishop h8
95 I mean that looks like such a great
position and then g4 next let's do that
and I'm not concerned if Bishop takes
Sun the darks words will be much weaker
and there's Bishop h6 here too I guess
but also looks good for whites so the
plan was to do this and then g4 coming
next just so much initiative there's
also some ideas of this like Knight g4
and take on that five in the night h6
mates so Knight g4 black probably has to
play h5 then I can take take nine h6
King h7 then there's Knight takes f5
looks very close to working I mean but
also g4
so 94 h5 takes I guess there is also
block taking on g4
I mean g4 96 Queen f3 now before it
takes takes Queen a for Queen B 5 c4
it looks nice and all these lines been
looking for something concrete
maybe we're not three immediately I'm
gonna play coin off three immediately
leaving the tension hopefully as a
decent decision cuz if Bishop takes and
I can I mean I could take him to a g4 or
ninety seven okay
it's all in the Knights oh do I win the
night I forgot about that move oh I
guess I'm not winning the Knights that's
unfortunate
do I have 97 Cal play keying each one
that's not what I wanted I should have
gone for 97
ah such a good position to mishandle
that's just forgot about Queen g5 at
least I still have some play like f4 g5
and Knight g4 and some idea
I haven't sneezed in a while on stream
probably allergic to making oversights
like that
f-for good playoff for right away why
not
okay so that's reasonable if g5 9f5
and let's take first so the lights a
little bit stuck I still have activity
extra puncture black doesn't mean too
much but it will become a question how I
make progress
maybe some f5 move eventually this could
be a long game though this game could go
the rest of the tournament potentially
imagine ting putting the Queen on each
three okay that's a move the Queen age
three with some idea of doing this this
takes takes either rook belongs I'm
gonna play rook here first and then put
the other hook here and maybe lift over
at some points I guess I'm a long queen
before Queen before I'd probably play
rook a d1
cuz the night needs some babysitter
lights just kind of stuck which means
the queen basically has to stay on e7 so
I'd like to take advantage of this
somehow g5 9f5 take C takes maybe you'll
put the rook on e to can lead to some
eventual tactics yeah
the rook on e2 aligns with the Queen and
also prepares some rookie 3 move
not sure what else black can be
considering here maybe Queen takes t4
but then I just take the knight f6 what
a move
I have 97
where are my moves I have this move too
but then the Queen takes on d4 so 97
things are getting sharp let's play 97
attacking the rook I'll probably wanna
pawn back somehow even though d4 is kind
of hanging black probably doesn't have
time to take it if work off seven I
could take take take
rook F it's queenie five solid in
lobbyist positions and winding up with
just a better bishop tax bishop aligned
with my king but not too impressive yeah
if i were to capture the knight right
away black would take and the queen
would be eating some pawns
so okay I'm going for this sign 96 is a
major weakness d4 it's defended some
plan of just rookie to rookie one slide
over
yeah we're doing this slide can I take
here takes takes King f8 okay let's do
this first
oh but then we're got7 I could play f5
f5 looks amazing because the pawn is
pinned and he's both of these pawns now
our targets Oh the pawn is actually
pinned I was about to say in two
directions but ok most importantly so
the rook if black takes with Ag paw and
the G file opens if work f7 probably
Queen g5
now both pawns are pinned so I'm
essentially forking the pawns with my
own pawn so it's a it's a pawn fork or a
fork pawn and there's three attackers on
g6 only one defender
I might just leave the tension like if
rook g7 I might just play rook e1 Bishop
such a key player I don't think I'm
gonna win the tournament though there's
four minutes left in the tournament so
this will probably be the last game
which counts rook g7 is played
weights I forgot he unpinned himself I
completely forgot
black can take this way why did I do
that
it was unnecessary thankfully I'm
attacking the rook which is tied down to
the pawn I think it's so good for me but
that wasn't necessary bouquet it's still
good for whites
I think assuming I'm not missing
anything more
because now I just gotta be something
here where's my something takes takes
Queen g5 rook g7 I could take on f5
Queen e8 doesn't work ok let's take
first looking for and I could play over
g1 looks good later up G one g1 or g7
Queenie eights it's hard to calculate
under pressure let's play with g1 now I
want to win the scheme of where the term
it ends there's 2 minutes 10 seconds
left in the tournament my opponent has
admitted in 50 so I can't use more than
20 seconds of my time so if I get below
230 that's giving my opponent a chance
to prolong the game so it doesn't count
for the tournament
okay
positions so good do this yeah I didn't
want that to happen we're gonna get some
end game and do this first Oh
interesting let's keep a pin
each for I guess I just want to put the
pawn in each six if King GA that can
take on d5
I'm running low on time
let's take that didn't really solve
anything check check okay let's bring I
can't bring the King in like that
I'm down upon but I'm gonna win this one
but I probably don't want to take it too
early let's put the bishop more actively
place
yeah this games not counting for the
tournaments sadly I'll finish in second
still
weights take stick sticks t3 we both
queen it's complicated but what else do
I do I guess I can do take stick sticks
Queen Queen each Queenie tribes not
possible I'm gonna go for this line
I mean f1 yeah cuz if I can win h6 I'll
be happy okay I'm happy and then it's a
matter of defending ooh probably
shouldn't have allowed that all right I
shouldn't allow Queen trade in some
cases
yeah queen g6 I think is useful because
I keep on ending is winning okay
good game I was I mean I like my
position at many different stages
somehow I didn't get anything I probably
should have taken that five sooner Queen
e7 was a good move and then I came down
to time
yeah rookie one was careless though I
should probably take on g6
or even a six for that matter if I take
on e6 takes takes I don't have Queens
Yates and then recap one is winning yeah
not the best technique but a fun game
that was a nice opening I like this this
preparation with the early e5 a lot of
the line hey it's bits cheering at the
right time not trying to distract me
during the game like some people thinks
Hearts wise a mule 1000 bits what place
did I finish in my finishing second
finishing second congratulations
Eugene all crushing everyone scoring 32
points even if I caught up and we were
tied at 32 I think he'd still finish
first because I think the tie break is
whoever reaches the score first will
finish higher so that was a good turnout
over 250 players